not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah's book like
you've never had before
[Music]
foreign
so i got an english bible and so i
started studying i started taking notes
i downloaded the bible app um
i joined elevation church was which is
like an organization
from north carolina and they would
broadcast
their sessions online so i would watch
like two or three times a week you know
church
and so um
yeah and that started that and so
everything was going fine you know um
and i've always always prayed and i
always asked
god to guide me to always
to make me a better person to um
to lead me to the right path right so in
this video um popped up
it was christianity and islam at the
time i didn't know anything about islam
i didn't know what a muslim was
the area i live in i can count on my
fingers how many muslims i've seen
muslim women
that i've seen
it's not too much i don't know any
anything
where where i live there's
just probably like nine churches around
me just where i live
so it's a very christian community
so when i um yeah so that's all i knew
so i was just trying to get back into
you know finding god and
doing what's right
so
this video popped up it's about
christianity versus islam i think it was
the mohammed hijab in
david wood
okay debate
yeah
yeah so i i kept delaying that video for
weeks but it just kept on popping up
whenever i watch church online wow it
just kept on popping up yeah
so
i was like
let me just watch this video
and even though it's two hours long um
let me just concentrate and watch this
video
um
i wasn't really taking sides
because i was still learning about
christianity and i didn't know what
islam was
so i was just kind of in the middle
i was trying to you know humble myself
you know and listen to
i think it was muhammad hijab so
yeah and i watched the video and then
after that it was like
my whole mindset changed i'm like
islam
one god
christianity
trinity
so three
but islam seems so much simpler than
christianity
why is that
so then i started watching more of
muhammad hijab videos
and then your videos and i and then i
just kept learning about islam for about
seven to eight months wow so um
yeah eventually i
i kept watching videos about
christianity and islam compared and then
eventually i just started watching
videos just about islam
so once i learned
more about islam
and that
i really didn't
believe in christianity anymore
it was just something
that i just grew up with no one really
taught me that much
okay even though my family has two
pastors they own a church but my my part
of the family they
we weren't really devoted like i said
so he wasn't
he wasn't that pr okay would you say
that he was at a point of your life
where
he was not
was you ever a practicing christian
no i don't think so okay so did you have
a moment in your life where you was like
okay i want to be a practicing christian
yes
so then
is that when you made the prayer to god
or did did that happen after so did you
say okay god guide me i want to be a
practicing christian or did you want to
be a practicing christian and then ask
god for guidance
i
yeah i wanted to be a practicing
christian and then ask god for guidance
i think that's how it was okay yes so um
yeah i um it just came a point i think
it was december 28th it was that night
where
it was time for me to go to bed and i
wanted to pray
but i no longer wanted to pray
you know the christian way
so out yeah so i just got up and went to
bed
and then
for four hours i just cried because i
just didn't know how to pray i just
didn't know how to what to believe in i
didn't know um
how to please god
i was very almost confused but i knew i
wanted to be muslim
okay so you know when it comes to um